well teachers are walking out again
today reluctantly they don't want to be
here they'd much rather be in the
classroom but we haven't had any further
negotiations with the Secretary of State
since uh Easter she put an offer on the
table then that was resoundedly rejected
by our members but also the head teacher
unions and other unions in education the
reason for that was because that head
teachers were extremely concerned
but that offer wouldn't be fully funded
and two schools were telling us that
they would have to make cuts to subject
provision and to teaching support
assistants if that pay was going to be
implemented now we've had forty thousand
nine percent of the education profession
leave teaching in the last last Academic
Year the government hasn't hit its
targets for new recruitment for ITT
students and if that continues they are
going to have a real problem from
September of ensuring that there's a
specialist qualified teacher in every
classroom for every child
and on the issue of pay I spoke to the
education Minister Robert Halford in the
last hour and he told me that the
government had to weigh up the full
economic position that the country was
in he said the deal they are offering
teachers was fair to the taxpayer as
well as fair to teachers
well they said that they would listen to
and take on board the the recommendation
from the school teacher review body that
they claim the independent review body
now they've had that report for a number
of weeks now and yet haven't published
it we're extremely concerned that that
means that they aren't going to fully
Implement that independent report and
and they absolutely do have to weigh up
the consequences that if we continue to
have the numbers of teachers leaving the
profession because of poor pay because
of pay has not kept up with inflation or
with other graduate professions that the
education secretary is going to have a
problem of not having enough teachers to
prove provide a world-class education
that our children so much deserve and
parents will recognize this they will
see that their schools are unable to
recruit teachers in a whole range of
secondary subjects and primary teachers
in particularly in London where I am
today finding it extremely difficult to
recruit teachers because of the cost of
living in the center of the city
some of the rail unions have said
they're willing to to strike for a
decade how long are teachers prepared to
strike for
education professionals means that we're
putting a generation of Children at Risk
that that's the reason our members have
taken seven or eight days of action
because they want to support the
education of this generation this
generation who have lived through
austerity who have lived through a
national pandemic who are in some of the
largest class sizes in the world the
only countries that have larger class
sizes than us are Mexico chile and
Colombia that's what our education
National Education union members are
striking for they're striking for this
generation because they want to make a
difference to our society
this is the last day of term for it for
a number of schools isn't it why did you
pick today there are some people that
are saying that it will mean that pupils
will miss out on some of the end of term
activities that they might have enjoyed
well there is no good day for a school
teacher to strike they don't want to
make additional disruption to children's
education and we apologize for
disruption that we may be causing to
those activities but we gave the legal
notice we gave as much notice as we
could so that those events could be
rearranged if possible but the real
disruption to Children is if they come
back to the classroom in September and
you know we have over a million children
in classes over 30. we have a real
danger of them not having an English
teacher teaching them English you know I
have I know a year seven coming to the
end of her first year of secondary
school who has had 24
temporary English teachers now that has
a huge impact on a child's life chances
and their enjoyment for secondary school
and a subject that's what this
disruption is about today to try to end
that for all students
Deputy General Secretary of the National
Education Union we appreciate your time
this morning thanks very much indeed